[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
were you pretty happy with the show last
week
yeah it was pretty solid I noticed
Johnny Smith didn't make the show but
Josh hild it what happened there yeah he
was in the article I mean you know we
got to make some changes here and there
but but he was there he was there oh no
matter
are you happy with how Kenny Stills
looked look I can't control who's gonna
catch the foot by to throw the football
I just do what I think makes sense and
last week it makes sense to play Kenny
Stills all right what happened with the
Lions backfield you know what we've got
that wrong okay simple as that they
decided to use multiple running backs ty
Johnson we didn't have carry on I don't
know Trey Carson is but now we know
we'll improve how about the ice cream
did you eat it when it fell on the
ground was a yummy listen that's a
stupid question you know it wasn't yummy
I would never say it was yummy it's
sitting next to a cigarette you know
what that's dumb I don't have time for
this what I do have time for is you
because it's time for your fantasy fire
drill
Wow from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace soon Fabulous Las Vegas is your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
[Applause]
hey welcome into your fantasy a fire
drill I am mad camp and we are here in
Las Vegas at the Caesar sports book and
you can find us right here every single
Sunday 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific on all
bleacher report platforms we got a
football game going on right now in the
AFC South but across the pond between
the Texas and the Jaguars we'll give you
updates from that game during the show
what else we do we'll talk about the
injuries the inactives all coming your
way my sleepers a matte moment we'll
talk a little evaluation mode and we'll
get to plenty of your questions you tube
to get your own section again and as
soon as the show's over I'll jump in the
app and answer another thirty minutes of
your questions before before we get to
your injuries your inactive a little
campfire discussion we haven't done one
of these in a couple of weeks but it's
time to talk tight and turmoil no it's
not the rockers in the headbangers or
whatever it's not that kind of match
this is tight end turmoil not tag team
turmoil we have a lot of tag teams going
on right now at the tight end position
and it's driving us nuts what am I
talking about well let's take a look at
this very festive and informative
graphic of the Eagles right the Eagles
we love Zach Ertz we took Zach Ertz at
the top three tight end he's not playing
at that level now not to tell you to sit
him don't go that far but he's not
ranked to my top three or even my top
five this week why Dallas got hurt has
found his way in the mix you might be
using Dallas Goddard what about the
Colts Eric Ebron Jack Doyle kind of
canceling each other out but not enough
to say you'd bench them completely
especially today with no tu I Hilton we
talked about the Buccaneers OJ Howard's
out today can Cameron break bill Vaughn
a decent amount of targets last week
we'll get into that on the show the
Titans I love John who Smith has it was
sleeper last week yes but what about
Delanie Walker
well Delaney Walker's gonna be out this
week has John who's Smith become a
top-ten tight end could be the case
plenty out there we'll talk about the
Jets it's a position that continues to
drive us nuts and you have to continue
to hit the waiver wire and play the
matchups but now we get into your early
game and
to injuries what we know right now will
update this throughout the show as we
get more information but what do we know
for right now Delanie Walker is out
today just talked about Johnny Smith I
think the Titans would be smart to make
Johnny Smith the permanent number one
tight end on top of their depth chart
he's my number 9 tight end for the week
Kurtis Samuel banged up for the Panthers
not sure about him quite yet we did find
out though that Cam Newton may not be
back anytime soon don't love Curtis
Samuel don't love DJ more today Adam
Thielen is in he's going to be active
today against the Kansas City Chiefs
let's hope the hamstring doesn't act up
there in the game but obviously you're
playing him at minimum as a top 15
option
Patrick mahomes we know is out today was
listed as questionable so it's a good
Chinese trending in the right direction
but not back quite yet you're still
playing Tyree kill you're still playing
Travis Kelce with confidence he wouldn't
Matt Moore Louie saw it last week Matt
Moore did a fine job in that offense
he's just not patrocle Holmes Chris
turned in for the Jets
we're not don't have an official word on
him but he could be back this week I'm
not saying he's a lot to play hopefully
he finds his way into the top 10 top 12
in the coming weeks DeSean Jackson is
officially back today for the
Philadelphia Eagles and thank goodness
for that I've hung on to him since week
one when he had that two touchdown date
game he's gonna help Carson wins he's
gonna help the offense as a whole he's a
wide receiver three with wide receiver
to upside so good to have him back ttyl
Hilton he's out today for the Colts a
big bummer a guy who usually can play
without practice not happening this week
Zach Pascal is a deep sleeper and I
think you can take a look at me Brian
and Jack Doyle if you're really hurting
at the tight end position James Conner
not gonna play today for the Steelers
we're gonna see Jalen Samuels out there
he's a top 15 top 15 option by the way
how about the report that came out that
the Steelers were looking at getting lay
beyond bail back that's just
mind-blowing to me now your late-game
inactives
we have some information here obviously
not all locked in but OJ Howard he's out
today Cameron great missed the day of
practice he's good to go
if you're reaching deep I think it could
be a top 12 option and the key might be
a better option in this offense the no J
Howard which is really more on bucerias
than anything but not a bad option today
Devon
they Addams we're gonna see it's a
game-time decision he's far from a lock
to play I would tell you to throw them
in your Flex spot so you have the
opportunity to get them in your lineup
if you have to pivot elsewhere you could
always do so but you want to plan if
he's active Hollywood Brown we'll see
about him against the Patriots the
matchups not great anyway he'd be a wide
receiver three if he is active James
White and Julian Edelman both should be
fine a white popped up with a toe injury
I also have a toe injury I'm playing
today you're gonna see James White and
Edelman's fine and Shepherd is cleared
from this concussion I just got a
question on him from the great Nate
Corddry who asked me about him I said
yeah you could throw them in there as a
wide receiver three so we'll get to more
of the early game and active as we lock
those in later on in the show but now we
get to your first run of questions for
week nine and potentially beyond let's
see we have here gat P traded away
mahomes Freeman and feeling for Adams
and Chubb breezes my backup that's okay
I think he gave away too much though I
don't know if you really upgraded enough
they're not a bad deal not a bad idea
trade mahomes by the way if you have
somebody like reason Robbie Anderson
Shepherd
Landry Singletary for the Flex I'll tell
you to play Robbie Anderson he's got the
dolphin so we're gonna talk more about
Sam Donald coming up in a little bit
next question here
Bama trade Emanuel Sanders and Eckler
for Hopkins I love that deal and I like
what Emmanuel Sanders did this is a
great move here because it is selling
Sanders high like them in San Francisco
but it's getting a top receiver and
DeAndre Hopkins would cy hurt I can
start either Shepherd crowd or LAN Jie
PPR I kind of like Shepherd against the
Cowboys on Monday night doesn't scare me
too much could be some garbage time
there for Shepherd Giants defense thinks
more pass attempts there I have the Pats
T but also Lamar Jackson L man I've
gotten this question a bunch today
should I sit Jackson for cousins or play
Jackson
I have Jackson at six that's the lowest
I've ranked him since week one I'm not
gonna tell you he's gonna be great
he's probably gonna have one of his
worst games of the season but he can run
and still make up for it I'm gonna play
both I start in that cat for Marvin
Jones
I have Marvin Jones higher I like them
both so I'll tell you to play Jones both
guys are good we go to the wall though
now for a viewer question
[Music]
we are a multi-species show here on your
fantasy fire drill and are you a
beautiful dog asking about Nick Chubb of
the dog pound or Sony Michele I'm I'm
good with playing Nick Chubb today I
think the Browns will control that game
against the Broncos Broncos run defense
nothing great it's nice to be in that
spot Casoni Michele not really worrying
me too much against the Ravens but I
like Nick Chubb I still think he's an RB
1 I am very intrigued to see what
happens with Kareem hunt comes back we
talked about that in the preseason will
they find ways to get him involved will
it hurt Nick Chubb we'll see about that
but I'm playing Nick Chubb today aria
thank you for your question ok what's
going on duck season winning okay we got
Watson he's doing quite well 173 yards
one touchdown running he's got a 33
doing pretty good without Sherlock Wow
pretty good right alright darling bye
she's really sleepers from last week
come on I don't even like her Instagram
post anyway Kenny Stills came through
four catches 52 yards and this on
Watson's having a nice game Darren fells
one of my sleepers has already hit today
that's good well we'll have more of
those coming up but now more of your
questions
for week nine and of course be honest
we're seeing some of the trades John
Rose Smith or TJ Hawkinson good question
there I'm in on Johnny Smith let's keep
rolling with them Ryan Tannehill
unlocking the offense for the Tennessee
Titans next up so I start Josh Allen or
Sam Donald from Jimbo
I'm gonna go Alan there I like both
quarterbacks hint in you might see Sam
Donald in like two minutes
but I'll go with Alan for you today next
one up here so I start Jack Doyle or
Eric Ebron I'm gonna go Ebron you don't
have to you I hope and I think they're
gonna be more red zone targets there for
them kind of tough to flip a coin we'll
go with Eric Ebron have him rank a
little bit higher Vance McDonald or
Cameron great I'm gonna go with great
there might be a bit of a controversial
call but I think there's more chances
for him in the offense today for the
Buccaneers against the Seahawks David
Montgomery are Jalen Samuels
I'm going to trust jail and Samuels as
the guy for the Pittsburgh Steelers
backfield I just can't get there yet
with Chicago with Montgomery as good as
he was last week we need to see that
happen multiple weeks in a row John
Brown our Melvin Gordon I'm gonna play
John Brown simple as that I feel better
about him against the Redskins Melvin
Gordon unfortunately I don't think he's
getting used correctly or they know what
they're doing with that backfield go to
the wall here for a bleacher report
personality question what's up guys I'm
in Germany just finished playing five
aside sock over NFL fantasy is always on
my mind maybe you can help me with this
conundrum do I start
DJ more or one of my two Titans boys
Corey Davis or AJ Brown let me know good
question we're all over the worlds here
so we come from Germany here and I'm
gonna tell you the DJ Moore is probably
the safe play I don't exactly get
excited about him for the Panthers I
think AJ Browns you're up side play
you're down big from Thursday night did
you play against Kenyan Drake this for
anybody did you play against Manuel
Sanders you got to go for that upside
take a look at AJ Brown I think that's
worth a look thank you for that question
we'll get more your questions coming up
a little bit but now it's time to perk
up for my sleepers
[Music]
so last week
Johnny Smith was in there Cole Beasley
we've been hitting we'd been doing okay
on these don't to ask him about Trey
Carson I know he was on the graphic and
anyone on the IR okay he's gone let's
just forget about him well we're gonna
focus in on the quarterback sleepers I
got two for you today we'll start with
this one that's Sam Donald there he is I
told you was coming sand Arnold's has
the Dolphins I'm running the platform
you know it always follow the Dolphins
it's a rule on this show everybody knows
that our crew knows it now you know it
as well when in doubt follow the dolphin
Sam Donald's got top ten potential this
week because he gets to take on the
Miami Dolphins didn't trade Robbie
Anderson so he's got our weapon maybe
even Chris Hearn in place we'll find out
about that a little bit another
quarterback were going back to him we
had him last week he hit we're going
back to Derek Carr today why Lyons pass
defense is not good you know what else
is not good the Raiders pass defense we
can have all kinds of points on the
board in this game today I'll go back to
Derek Carr Tyrell Williams Hunter Renfro
Darren Waller hopefully the throw and
Josh take us the ball a little bit no
defense in this game a lot of Derek Carr
and speaking of that game let's give you
a wide receiver on the other side of
this one for the Detroit Lions Danny
Amendola has been a target monster the
last couple of weeks could he put up 16
plus fantasy points for a third straight
week my answer to you is yes that's
going to happen today as he takes on a
very beatable Oakland Raiders secondary
we love points and points come from
games with bad defenses lions and
raiders that's one of those games
we'll get now to your questions and
we'll go to YouTube hello YouTube I'm
here for you let's see what you have for
me
Edelman Hiller Davante Adams who has
these kind of questions how can you sit
one of these guys apparently two of
these guys we're gonna play Tyree kill
getting a bigger league than a four-man
League next Montgomery Singletary Adrian
Peterson
we're gonna go Montgomery and hope that
he gets enough touches to make up for
what he did last week and do it yet
again Thank You Colin for that one next
one here Sony or Jordan Howard got to
play Sony Michele wanted out go the
Patriots
the man is leading the NFL and inside
the 10 carries that means scoring
opportunities bills or Pat's team Tyler
you never sit the Patsy I don't care who
they're playing anis toric season going
on through the first half of the year
you keep rolling with the Pats defense
next up here Frank gourds mile William
Stanley from Joseph I'm playing Jamal
Williams the Packers have figured it out
Aaron Jones is great smile Williams
pretty darn good as well they're using
both guys a lot of success you're gonna
play Jamal Williams today
next up Ronald's old redeeming Williams
from Moe shop don't really like either
guy I'll lean towards Damian Williams
why it's a better offense we're gonna
take you guys out though into the sports
book because we have people that got up
early because it is early out here on
the west coast and they wanted to
actually ask me a question we're gonna
do that right now and you might know
this person cuz he's coming up right
after me on this show Kathy how are you
I'm wonderful how are you all right
what's your question how can I help you
who do I start who do I sit I have a
couple of quarterbacks for you Carson
Wentz playing versus Chicago right dak
Prescott playing in New York that's your
guy that Prescotts the guy could could
be the number one quarterback this week
it's a very beatable Giants defense you
got to wait a little bit for it but it's
gonna pay off for you with deck
thank you I lose my week then why come
and find me in the green room
there's cabby you can catch them on the
betting show coming up next but right
now there's the piano music it's time
for a matte moment so what exactly do
you do for Cincinnati the quarterback I
throw the ball you physically throw the
football you throw the ball how far
wherever the receivers run to what else
can I do i don't have AJ Green what am I
supposed to do I'm Andy Dalton I throw
or I throw um it seems like a lot of the
time Andy you throw the football
four yards well I need it to be thrown
12 yards I try to get the players
involved I want them to make their moves
and do what they do they're they're
talented people why don't you just throw
12 yards I'm trying this well I can't
always throw a 12 it's hard behind that
offensive line what am I supposed to do
when I don't have time to throw it 12
hours I have to throw it for you know
here
he's a check down charlie coach he knows
he knows the guy in LA this should all
work just give me time I need time I've
been to the playoffs multiple times yeah
you didn't win any of those games oh I'm
a check down Charlie I can do this
that was my best Andy Dalton impression
could you tell the red and just losing
his mind and getting mad we are in week
9 usually I don't bring this
conversation of this phrase up for like
three or four more weeks but we're an
evaluation mode for some teams the
Redskins fired Jay Gruden weeks ago now
they got the Broncos Joe Flacco's on the
bench you got a neck injury Andy Dalton
gets benched that Andy no more the
Dolphins are clearly tanking some of
these teams are taking a look at what
they have could be bad backup
quarterbacks could be younger players
Kenyan Drake Coast Arizona Emanuel
Sanders shipped away to San Francisco
we're gonna start to see these deaf
players move into bigger roles that's
not necessarily a good thing until we
know who's getting that playing time and
it's very early in the season so you
might be wanting to avoid these teams
you're gonna feel good about AJ Green
coming back with a backup quarterback
probably not so evaluation would have
started for some of these teams and it's
coming for more teams in the future so
beware of evaluation mode now we go back
to the wall because we have more
injuries we update you on the inactive
or our early games here let's refresh a
couple of these
Delanie Walker is out I like John Smith
as a top ten option this week Kurtis
Samuel is going to play today he's a
wide receiver three at best they still
favor DJ more over them a little bit
Adam Thielen is in let's just hope he
gets through the game with the bad
hamstring you're gonna play them
obviously Patrick of Holmes is out
trending in the right direction was
listed as questionable this week it's
Matt Moore again I'm still playing
Tyreke he'll Travis Kelce with
confidence hopefully we see Patrick of
Holmes very soon
Chris Herndon welcome back am i putting
him in the top ten no but if you're
reaching deep he's got the Dolphins
not a bad guy again I've held them on a
lot of teams you could as well DeSean
Jackson also back this week for the
Philadelphia Eagles first time since
week one when he scored two touchdowns
good to see him back today gonna help
the offense as a whole wide receiver
three with wide receiver to upside CY
Hilton's out pascal's a deep reach can't
see me a Doyle and Eric Ebron if you
need some help a tight end or worth it
James Connors out today Jalen Samuels is
a top 15 option at the running back
position now late game and actives
news that we know as of now o J Howard
is out you could take a look at Cameron
Breit who did miss a day of practice
he's going to play later on today
Devante Adams looks like he could play
we're not quite sure yet just put him in
your Flex spot if you have nobody else
to go with maybe you don't want to risk
the zero and play somebody now I
understand that same thing with
Hollywood Brown against the Patriots
although for Brown the matchups not
great a little easier to keep him on
your bench later on of course James
White Julian Edelman listed as
questionable he's got to tell he's okay
Edelman's been unquestionable for like
weeks obviously it doesn't matter he
could be a top five option this week and
sterling Shepherd cleared from his
concussion he's back as a wide receiver
three against the Cowboys now we'll get
even quicker we're going to the speed
round
[Music]
it is time for the speed round powers
check down Charlie doing across the pond
back down Charlie the number one dance
and all the mean streets at Westminster
check the number one character in all of
this show let me give you a score in a
place nineteen to three them Houston
Texans are running all over the Jag was
Duke Johnson scampered to the end zone
like a new episode of Downton Abbey was
about to premiere how about that let's
get a speed round places Guy Ritchie to
produce this segment all right let's go
speed round time any questions can we
get answered for you let's start to my
Williams of Devon Singletary gonna go
with Jamal Williams has got a nice role
in the Packers offense keeping it up
here du jour Jalen Samuels has my Flex I
think I'm a little safer feel a little
safer but Jalen Samuels with James
Connor out today
next one here trade James Connor for
Josh Gordon Westbrook no I have no
interest in Josh Gordon Westbrook didn't
even play today for the Jaguars forget
about that stop with the Josh Gordon
optimism it couldn't happen doing it you
think it's gonna happen in Seattle Voice
3 min or James White I like Freeman
against the Bronco browns today not a
bad matchup and they continue to use
them so I'm gonna go with Roy screaming
over James White
Cole Beasley or Zack Pascal flex PPR
Josh channels my quarterback we've gone
with Beasley he's scored the last couple
weeks I'll fire him up again let's go
for three with Cole Beasley Tyrell d dat
Lamar Jackson or snapper to start this
week I have Stafford one spot higher
love the matchup against the Raiders a
rare time I'll tell you to sit down
Lamar Jackson's got the Patriots today
Brady or Josh talent Alexander I think
Brady they'll be good not great today
I think Alexander could do quite well
always has the legs we're gonna play
Alexander over Tom Brady next DeSean
Jackson over my flames bloodline I'm ok
with it it's an upside play if you want
to do what Mike Williams a little safer
you tell me where you're ready
hufflepuff get him Harry get him ok next
Devante got with juju Gallup who was
sitting three of these players you never
see Chris Cobb when he's in the top
three you're gonna play him how are you
possibly sitting one of these guys will
sit too
go singleterry scary Terry or Hollywood
Brown I'll play Maclaurin I don't love
the matchup but Hollywood banged up and
I don't know if single Terry's gonna get
enough touches for the Buffalo Bill so
scary Terry it is a fear Shepherd for
Logan Shepherd back against the Cowboys
I'm happy to have him back and I'm gonna
play him do not like Peterson today
are we sleeping on Amendola 16r
interceptions on 19 targets last week
start over Morgan Jones Greg I'm not
starting over Martin jokes but I'm
certainly not sleeping on him because he
is a sleeper can you play them both
because I think it's worth it today for
the Detroit Lions and Shepherd back to I
started obj or tape I'm starting Beckham
he's got the Broncos it's okay it's not
a great matchup
I'm not sitting unless it's a real
obvious answer tape isn't an obvious
answer pick two Marlin Matt Kenny G
Hakeem down Kenny G Kenny G and Keenan
Allen are in your lineup men man that's
what we're going with
and that's what you need we did it I
think we did it here are people that are
good all they're doing expected of
Charlie you don't have to see this if
you come through the app because that's
what I'm gonna be for the next 30
minutes taking your questions and we're
gonna be here with you next week and
every Sunday at the sports book at
Caesars and on all bleacher report
platforms 8:30 Pacific 11:30 Eastern for
your fantasy fire drill for my British
friends i'm matt camp good luck in week
9 we'll see you next week
you
you